fantastic beasts and where to find them
delightful witty interesting thematic
different to what we were doing before
as the same spirit the same warmth the
same weight but it's set in a new time a
new place and has brand new characters
hey mr. English guy I think your egg is
hatching Eddie is quintessentially
British is kind of soulful and it has
enormous humanity and I think unique and
all of those qualities special and
important for nukes commander year ago
with the case full of monsters a huge
travels first there are some moments in
fantastic beasts and where to find them
the imax version there are different to
the regular version that people will see
in regular theaters and that's when we
occasionally break the frame and and
just let the movie spill out into the
auditorium a little bit i don't think
i'm dreaming pop gave it away I ain't
got the brains to labor's up so we chose
moments which we felt were emotionally
justifiable and which enhance the
storytelling there are various moments
in time square towards the end of the
movie when there's some of the sort of
flame effect the embers float out into
the theater I might bring something
extra and it brings scale and and a sort
of sense of immersion in the story we
got a plan right guys they need our help
was that everything that came out of the
case the big major set-piece action
sequences are always great for the nine
nights and the beast will be even bigger
and better on imax what I love about I'm
act it's a tremendously immersive
experience for the audience the sheer
scale of the image is fabulous and the
quality of it is always very exciting
I want to be a wizard